into that i that i kind of find issue
with when
um people talk about it they go you're
just gonna give up a life so easy i was
like who's who said it was easy yeah
it's not a [ __ ] easy decision man
were you with the these these women or
the you know the couple that was there
that had to decide to let go of this
child like who said it was easy yeah you
said it was easy to go through this
whole procedure
i i don't understand why you're assuming
like for them it's like you know like
changing underwear like what the [ __ ]
are you in five four three
two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
uh it's another crazy
day in the states
interestingly what else is new bro hey
everybody else is new before we get into
that [ __ ] dude the the craziest thing
happened in la so did you was it raining
where you were at no
it wasn't raining no it was raining over
here dude a couple days ago it was
thunderstorms and lightning storms so i
saw the the storm clouds yeah and when i
was looking at the weather forecast it
was saying like about 30 chance rain in
l.a but it ended up not raining oh so in
here yeah pasadena yeah pasadena area
yeah bro it was raining non-stop it was
a thunderstorm that's crazy it was
well originally so i was sleeping at
night right
and it's like
12 a.m
and then somebody's like
pushing their garbage
out so you just hear this rumbling right
and i'm like yo who the [ __ ] is putting
out their garbage at [ __ ] 12 a.m at
[ __ ] in the morning i was pissed yeah
and it just kept going oh i was like
wait that's not it's thunder
and then you hear just a flash ring and
then all of a sudden it starts raining
like insane yeah
so the next day
i hear this rumor that somebody got
struck by lightning
and around here yeah and i was cracking
the [ __ ] up i was like who the [ __ ]
there's no [ __ ] way somebody got
struck by lightning i see a news article
this lady goes out walks her dogs right
now
she gets struck by [ __ ] lightning
holy [ __ ] she get her and her two dogs
get fried did they die they died oh [ __ ]
they got blasted by zeus holy bro
and when i heard this i was kind of
making jokes about i was like there's no
[ __ ] way because what's he saying
that's like getting struck by lightning
yeah it's like yeah yeah of course like
one in a billion or trillion or whatever
this lady and both her dogs got [ __ ]
roasted up even the dogs got [ __ ]
roasted so you said
talks me down listen i'm not even sure
if this was like if they did this for
like dramatic effect but i was watching
the thing on the news and it was they
showed this one scene where it's just
like two three piles of ashes so i'm
just like that's not that's not
really that's not how it happened so i
don't know why they did that so i'm
watching this and i'm cracking the [ __ ]
up because i'm like somebody took the
artistic license
to take a photo or like a video footage
of three things of ashes which clearly
isn't them it's not what happens dude
the disintegration digits ash it's not a
[ __ ] anime dude yeah no but the thing
is though remember that night when uh me
you and ed went to go eat at denny's and
i kept telling y'all yo you guys see
those flashes and you guys didn't see it
until [ __ ] like the car ride down
we were in the [ __ ] eye
but it wasn't like that back in l.a
though so it's over here it's i don't
know maybe because the mountains and
ships mountains or something so yeah i
don't remember the exact part of valley
that she lived in but it was in the
mountains okay yeah it was like in the
hilly mountains areas yeah and every
morning she goes and walks her two
little tiny dogs and then her landlord
was trying to call her and then she
wasn't around because she got struck by
the way was she old though was she like
she was an older lady well she was like
i would say in her 50s oh that's not too
old she's pretty young yeah yeah but
legit just to go walk her dogs and then
lightning [ __ ] hit her dude
what are the chances of that [ __ ] there
has to be a statistic no it i it's like
it's it's like winning the [ __ ] lotto
man it's it's like one in a i don't know
a billion or some [ __ ] it's it's it's
very very very unlikely dude then i saw
this this video going around people were
freaking out because biden fell off his
bike oh that [ __ ] was
did you see the clip dog
you know what the saddest thing is like
i'm watching this [ __ ]
and then
people are trying to analyze his video
you're like why did he fall i'm like you
know why he fell because he's 80 [ __ ]
thousand years old it's cause this man
is literally a fossil that's why
prehistoric dude man the [ __ ]
audacity of this man to think that it's
okay for him to ride a speed bike but
the thing is he looked good
leaving
he stops he gets up and then it just
falls right over it's like nothing
happened i'm like well how did that even
[ __ ] this dude just grabbed he got
the best of him that is totally the
oldest [ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever seen in my
life where he can't even balance off of
a bike anymore he's actually in his 80s
isn't he yeah he is the [ __ ] is he doing
riding a bike you know what the
hilarious [ __ ] is the next day i think
it was a day or two afterwards that
incident happened he was coming out of a
building and he started dancing to show
people that he's okay
take it easy
dude you [ __ ] old old [ __ ]
this guy is so old like every time i
look at him i think he literally looks
like the [ __ ] keeper like how was this
guy the president of the united states
every time he's talking i'm always
thinking to myself this is it
yeah he's gonna die on national
broadcasting dude he is so do you know
what his [ __ ] first book he ever read
was was the [ __ ] the new testament
when it was actually old testament when
it was written
that's what that [ __ ] did helped
write the whole test yeah
that was his bedtime story this old [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] yeah that was oh man i was
crack i mean i'm sorry it's [ __ ] up
but i was cracking up dude it was too
[ __ ] fun because there was nothing
that caused it there was not like oh oh
oh oh i'm losing my he just
dude it's like then i went into this
whole rabbit hole of biden just doing
old people things
there's so many things because i don't
really follow politics like that but
this guy there's a point where he was
doing a speech right
finish his speech he doesn't rather
shake somebody's head nobody's there
nobody's there
what was that that he holds his hands
out yeah for the longest time dude he's
probably confused as [ __ ] he's like
where did the guy go i was like there
was nobody there but that's you know
what at the same time there's still this
very famous clip of trump doing
something very similar yeah which had me
dying laughing he starts doing this
speech he goes he goes i really wish uh
my wife my beautiful wife melania is
here and she's right next to him yeah
you see her face i remember that oh [ __ ]
did you just say [ __ ] i just rode with
you in our private jet together what are
you talking about
oh man we get we get [ __ ]
back-to-back presidents like this man
holy [ __ ] dude but
the biggest topic that we want to talk
about and listen i don't know too much
about anything really
but i definitely know what roe v wade
was for right right and you know for the
longest i went for the longest time i
say for the past like maybe a couple of
months they were talking about roe
versus wade being turned over and you
know when you kind of hear these things
you don't really think it's going to
happen because i don't know whether it's
because i live in california or you know
we've always grew up in a very liberal
state yeah i just it's just the most
ridiculous thing i would never think
that that would happen well so here's
the thing this is like one of the
rare very rare instances
matter of fact some people in politics
thought this was the first time this has
ever happened right which is the supreme
court uh it gets overturned yeah well
they took away
um
they basically overturned the law and
took away a federal right you know but
um there was i believe a fact check on
this and there's like precedent of maybe
two times or something so it's like a
very very rare instance you know but
here in california
we're not going to be affected by this
yeah blue states matter of fact some of
the blue states have um doubled down on
abortion laws to reinforce it right and
i think it's not only to like continue
the protection of the of the right but
also in anticipation of people from
other states now coming over to get you
know if they do need an abortion right
you can get it yeah because some of
these red states they had what was
trigger laws in place so basically what
had happened was they already had a law
that would trigger the moment roe v wade
would get overturned so they had this in
place already so the moment the decision
came down boom
it went into effect
right i didn't know that should existed
i didn't either i didn't either there
was a lot of [ __ ] behind roe v wade that
i didn't know about until i looked into
it more as a result of the overturning
of this
and
here's this
kind of the sick [ __ ] with with uh some
of these red states is that
there's total bands and so
there's no exceptions for things like
rape incest health risks you just cannot
get an abortion
how [ __ ] up is that dude it's just so
you know what
the interesting thing is like
i had to
i don't know if this is because of like
the onslaught of the internet and how
much media has
has taught me to think a little
differently now just because of the
information that's out there yeah but
now what i what i used to do is
constantly look for things that already
uh fortify the things that i believe in
but i realized that i don't need to do
that anymore because i know why i
believe in this stuff right whether it's
whether it's through you know
legislative reasons or just more
morality in general now i need to
understand and i kind of picked this up
from when like you know growing up as a
christian kid when i was when i was a
christian kid and i remember having this
one conversation with this one person
who uh
was an atheist but this guy knew more
about the bible than i did right and
from that point on
what that put that point on but that was
just something that reminded me of like
okay
in order for me to let's say i had a
conversation with somebody down the
street right
i would have to understand their
position in order for in order for me to
have a conversation with them yeah and
so i started watching all these videos
of people who wanted to explain why they
believe that roe versus wade being
turned over is right and it's a lot of
it is tied towards religion it is it is
you know yeah it's it's
and then the biggest debate that kind of
goes on from it is the idea of when is
the
inception of a child like when is this a
person and when does it become murder
right right right and
this is where it's all up for grabs so
the idea of it for those people who
don't who truly believe that roe versus
wade being turned over is a good thing
is that they truly believe that abortion
is murder it's like walking down the
middle of a street coming up to a person
and blowing a [ __ ] their brains
outside their head yeah it's murder and
that's all that it is so once again i
don't agree with that but i'm trying to
understand the psyche of somebody who is
so adamantly against this its
indoctrination is what it is we'll get
into that because there's a very very
interesting historical fact
why people think that people think it's
their own thoughts and beliefs of
oh
abortion is murder right life starts at
conception
actually historically that's not what
the church said that is not what the
church said that's [ __ ] wild because
i'll tell you this because for me it's
like well where do we draw this line
right yeah because if we're talking
about murder in general hey when i jack
off i've been killing millions of babies
dude
but here's the thing man um 63 of
americans regardless of political
affiliation
did not want roe v wade overturned right
that's still a high number of people who
wanted overturned i'm kind of shocked i
know i know but still it's the majority
of americans didn't want it overturned
right
and 25 of americans which is the lowest
figure i believe in history
their vote of confidence um in in the
supreme court justice is at like the
historical low yeah yeah yeah um
so it's
here's the ironic thing and and sad [ __ ]
about this happening is that it affects
women in red states the most so people
whose affiliation
uh
party affiliation is the party that
wants this thing overturned yeah because
again people in states like us in
california we're not affected by this
but those women in those states are now
right and so regardless of all the
repercussions that might happen right
because look it's not just a matter
of murdering a baby or not
all right what if then the woman has a
major health risk if she has this child
and they know it and so they need to
abort the baby
but they say nope
you're going to have this child
okay that's getting ejected out like so
this woman's life is worthless now
basically is what you're saying you're
basically sentencing her to death so
that a baby can be born yeah right so
how does that work one thing is murder
and one thing isn't well so there's you
know i'll just give you the because i've
watched so many of these videos now like
i said i don't agree with this but this
is what they'll say they go what is the
percentage of this happening versus
people who abort it out of their free
will they give out this statistic of it
i don't know what the statistic is you
guys could look it up but i don't know
they say some arbitrary number of it
being really low and now they now they
argue the idea of like is this
small statistic here worth it for the
murder of like hundreds of thousands of
kids yeah no for sure and look like even
if
um
a woman who doesn't have access to
abortion has the kid it's not all
[ __ ] peaches and roses from that
point on right statistics are against
them right there's a very high
statistical chance like these are
socioeconomic
ramifications like a ripple effect of
negative socio economic things that will
happen where the women will most likely
have the women will most likely have a
poor quality of life the child will be
most likely born into poverty uh be less
educated as a result as a result of that
have higher chance of incarceration at
some point it's just like a ripple
effect you know there's there's this
ripple effect of socioeconomic things
that will happen as a result of somebody
bringing a child that wasn't capable
that or didn't want to or wasn't ready
whatever the reason is but people say no
that's
that's what it is though you know you
made that choice it's really hard to
like
have a conversation with somebody that
doesn't believe in abortion when they
themselves have not been in that
position that these other people have
been in right
and
like like i said for them it only i
can't
i'm trying to wrap i've been racking my
brain over just trying to how would i
tell them like okay
we don't believe it's murder like our
idea of when a living being is sentient
and is not at conception yeah you know
yeah and the idea that you believe that
this quote-unquote unborn child to well
for people who do believe in abortion
don't believe that this is a viable
living thing at that point
um is
worth having and destroying this
person's life and also this kid's life
that's good and then one person was like
well my parents were going to abort me i
turned out fine i was like cool well
that's you
but if we want to bring out the
statistics and we want to talk about
numbers once again i don't really know
that but for when i've seen i don't know
you once again you're going to have to
fact check this stuff because i don't
have the numbers in front of me and i
could be wrong but
the thing is is like people only want to
cherry pick the statistics that work for
them but that the ones that don't work
for them they'll completely ignore yeah
so they'll say well what are these how
many cases of rape are there that in in
terms of a baby being born is that
number worth this amount and then
somebody will say well i have a
statistic that says the the children's
who who are born in these very terrible
circumstances they have so many there's
a socio-economic downfall that happens
from them being born and this is the
chance that they'll either end up
incarcerated all this other stuff but
then they'll ignore that statistic so
it's like nobody nobody wants to talk to
each other and nobody can really figure
this stuff out and this like i'm saying
i'm actually shocked for me personally
that it was 40 and 60. i thought it was
like holy [ __ ]
i thought it was going to be like 80 20.
you know yeah
but here's the thing is that context
matters with a situation like this and
there is a lot of context that needs to
be provided because going back to
the the religious ideology
of
life happens at conception
that historically that's not where where
it was it was life happens at birth and
we'll get into that part because it's
very important to cover that because it
trickles all the way down from that and
then when you realize the history and
the indoctrination that happened it's
disgusting it's appalling it's shocking
and i
would bet my left nut that a lot of
these people who are out there
protesting um against abortion rights
have no clue about this history right
some of these people being minorities
and i'll tell you why that's especially
sad once once you learn about everything
that happened leading up to this you'll
know why it's sad that you see like
young black girls who are
anti-abortion rights
because
it actually stems from their oppressors
and they have no idea
why they believe what they believe but
okay so here's a little bit of context
right
is justice alito he's one of the supreme
supreme court justices he says that
abortion rights aren't deeply rooted in
american history and tradition and isn't
supported by the equal protection 14th
amendment which amendment which is a
point of contention right
but
uh if that's the case then
in regard to the 14th amendment anyway
it technically also applies to things
like our rights with contraception
interracial marriage uh where you care
where your children can go to school
same-sex marriage all of that is up for
grabs now right
so
it's setting kind of a scary precedent
here you know but
he kind of gave his explanation of why
this thing needs to be overturned and
why it shouldn't be a federal law and a
right
and
religious context also matters here in
explaining the situation and so where
this staunch stance on anti-abortion
rights stem from believe it or not is
from race issues
sounds weird right it's like what the
[ __ ] does abortion and race issues have
to do with one another right
but
so
basically here's let me let me uh read
you a little um excerpt from an article
right that'll kind of give you a context
and let's get into it right so at first
roe v wade was not nearly as important
as it would later become many catholics
opposed it but at the same time it was
decided most protestants said that
abortions should be legal and
evangelical preachers taught that life
began at birth
so the southern baptist convention which
is now a pillar of conservative
christian right
specifically endorse that view that life
happens at birth
um
so what happened evangelicals began to
get into politics pop
get into politics because of
desegregation
so when public schools were desegregated
in the 1950s white evangelicals and some
catholics left in droves the
evangelicals especially sending their
kids to so-called segregation academies
religious schools that only admitted
white people
at the same time as roe was being argued
those academies were found to be illegal
even though white christians protested
that their religious beliefs compelled
them to keep the races separated
conservative evangelicals and catholics
attended to avoid the mess of politics
and rarely agreed with one another but
with the courts forcing white christians
to go to school with black kids that
changed and in the light in the late
1970s the christian right was born so
that's when the right christian
conservative group was born as a result
of their dissatisfaction for
desegregation they didn't want their
white children being mixed with black
kids right
so from there um
yet there was a problem preserving
segregation was no longer an effective
unifying issue people started going away
from that they started believing equal
rights and yeah desegregation and none
of this white bathroom black bathroom
white school black school right
and so paul weirich uh
falwell and other founders of the
christian right in a history
meticulously documented by randall
bomber seized on abortion instead so
they're like we need something new this
is not working for us we need to seize
another issue that's gonna work right
abortion was perfect support for
abortion of overlap with support for
desegregation women's rights gay rights
and the sexual revolution if you fought
one you could fight the others too plus
abortion was an emotional issue that was
easily used to whip up anger and ending
indignation as well as to drive people
to the polls and donate money
and it worked it [ __ ] worked for them
so they latched on to abortion because
they were losing their grip right
through through trying to unify with
segregation
and then as a result
the start of this was getting ronald
reagan elected in the 80s and then from
that point on they vetted
people who
had this
i guess mindset and ideology
with who were pro
anti-abortion
and
were conservative christians so
this all stems from pretty much which is
the age-old story of america
old rich
powerful men
wanting to control what people can and
can't do in america
yeah
um so it it kind of all drives from that
and then um it pretty much starting from
the reagan era it uh abortion became a
defining issue for right-wing
conservatives that became like a pillar
of their thing
and so yeah man it's it's kind of crazy
to think that's that's what i was
alluding to earlier about like
seeing young black girls out there who
are talking about
who who are basically uh
anti-abortion rights
it's like well you were indoctrinated
because the church didn't used to say
that life happened at birth
they changed it because it didn't fit
their agenda anymore
they said no we need to flip this up now
segregation is not working for us
we need to seize a more sizzling topic
let's use abortion okay now how can we
use abortion to further our agenda how
can we control this issue now so that
it not only uh puts them in power but
stays in power
and it's a scary [ __ ] thing when you
look at it from that lens right yeah and
it shows you
how much power
the religious groups have
and not only religious groups but white
religious people how much power they
yield in this country
and how much that trickles down to the
everyday people and you know what the
interesting thing is like i don't even
know if like the modern day christian
believes in like abortion is murder
well well so here's the thing right is
it becomes a thing of semantics because
uh justice deleto was saying that
nowhere in the constitution does is the
word abortion used so it should not be a
protected right
but okay where in the bible does it
explicitly say that abortion is a bad
thing yeah
where in the bible does it say you
cannot abort a baby
people use verses and say there's
implications from those verses but you
can't say
anywhere in the bible explicitly says
abortion is a bad thing yeah and
abortion should not happen
well i don't know if the bible's gonna
be the greatest example of like the care
for human life when there's literally
literally been hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people who have been
murdered over like holy land so i don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
about the value of [ __ ] life yeah
when literally in the bible it's it's
literally an anthology of [ __ ] wars
like i don't know what the [ __ ] that i
where that idea comes from but this is
what i'm talking about people like to
cherry-pick constant things just to make
it fit their [ __ ] agenda right and
it's like
i don't understand
why this is man it's maybe it's so hard
for me to wrap my head around it aside
from the fact that they continually call
it murder yeah but in my in my mind i'm
like well that's such a slippery slope
to me right because if it's like oh the
moment that sperm goes into the egg then
it's it's a life yeah it's like well so
but that's the thing is that they they
changed that whole idea to favor their
agenda right well that's what i'm saying
like yeah it's it's a slippery slope
yeah like all right well if you believe
that this living organism and you know
it doesn't have
it's not a sentient being it doesn't
know that it's alive it doesn't have any
of this type of stuff right because
there's laws
there's laws put in place for
how far the baby is along before you can
abort it right because you can't abort
it like i forgot what the time there's a
time limit to it though
right so
there is like a certain defining moment
where it becomes like a sentient being
where before after that you can't abort
the baby yeah i'd be like i believe uh
with mississippi was like the 15-week
mark you can't pass the 15-week mark um
but prior to that or any any time prior
to that you can yeah yeah um but you
know that's the thing is that like
this whole idea of life
begins at conception
i mean
i don't i don't think the bible or
science supports that well yeah like i
don't i don't think that's what i'm
saying like for them it's just the
moment that sperm hits the egg then it's
it's life well i'll go like i said i'll
go even further yeah my sperm is half
dna of a human being right so when i
jacked off this [ __ ] morning i
literally killed millions of them yeah i
guess i'm a [ __ ] murderer too yeah i
guess like every time a girl has her
[ __ ] period and she ejects her eggs
right i guess she's a murderer too yeah
like what what is his [ __ ] nonsense
yeah i know but but i'm saying that
that's how that's how crazy it is though
though like the influence that the these
groups have had on people and and what
they believe because look the christian
fundamentalists only started supporting
pro-life candidates from that point on
once they decided they're latching on to
abortion you know they brought reagan
into office right and so now like okay
we're going to vet these people who
share
the same ideology as us this this these
religious ideologies and these are the
only people that we're going to help put
into power that's a scary scary thing
because you're talking about straight up
indoctrinating the american public based
on the poor are based on the people who
you put into power and the things that
they decide on you know and so
as we're seeing right it has trickled
down from the 70s on until now it's
still very present that ideology is
still very present today and you have
people regurgitating these ideologies
and these beliefs based on [ __ ] that
these old white men used to
overpower what are they saying too like
it's it's not just they're not just
trying to tackle abortion they're trying
to take away others yeah like
contraception you know same-sex marriage
rights like that's what i was saying
earlier right it's it's
kind of open season now on all of those
things as well
so
it's it's
it's a pretty it's a pretty [ __ ] up
situation and scenario and then i was
also watching this video of like you
know people being interviewed and
they're like oh well did you know that
it's not that they're banning abortion
everywhere they're just leaving it up
the stage it's like it's like that's any
[ __ ] better
yeah exactly how was that it should look
it shouldn't be
in my opinion
a politicized issue it should not be a
liberal versus conservative issue it
should not not be a left versus right
issue it should be a basic human rights
issue in a civilized society and world
right it should be a very very basic
human right but that's the thing they're
they're they're using that same argument
though i know like the same argument for
them is
this is murder so you can't take the
life away of something that's a living
being i know i know but i'm pretty but
at the same time in my mind i'm like but
i'm pretty sure you guys are the same
people that also believe in the electric
chair too so you're like
yeah
it's just there's a lot of like weird
semantics some weird hypocrisy like i
just don't
i don't understand it yeah yeah and so
here's here's a here's another point was
that like judges and justices were
basically vetted for their stances on
abortion rights and they had this
philosophy of originalism basically
originalism is the idea that right only
rights that were part of our nation's
history and tradition were covered by
the constitution's guarantees this is
what alito used to basically talk about
the the choice leading up to overturning
roe v wade right and it's a ridiculous
notion it was a ridiculous notion 50
years ago but
majority of our sitting justices on the
supreme court
believe in that they believe in
originalism now here's the crazy [ __ ]
six of the nine current supreme court
justices
were or are part of the federalist
society which is a large ring network
that grooms conservative law students so
it's sort of like a frat like a large
network of frat but only for
conservative religious people right
and then so they're bound by pretty much
this religious religious ideological for
uh
[ __ ] what's the word uh conformity right
and the man at the center of that
network is a dude named leo leonard now
this is a dude that i learned about
reading into this after roe v wade got
turned on who the [ __ ] is this leo
leonard right
so he's basically played a decisive role
in the appointments of some of these
conservative justices right
and so
this guy leo leonard he's part of an
extremely secretive and conservative
catholic order called the knights of
malta have you ever heard this knights
of malta yeah so corny as [ __ ]
so they function as a semi-independent
sovereign nation and they basically have
a lot of influence power land and reach
you know
and um leonard he figured out like
decades decades ago that conservatives
basically lost the uh culture war what i
was talking about earlier things like
the the segregation all that it wasn't
working for them people were getting
more progressive with their thoughts and
ideas right and abortion gay rights
contraception people were like nah man
we don't we don't [ __ ] with what you
guys are saying regarding that you know
that you guys are against it you know
we're actually for stuff like that now
wait why are they trying to stop
contraception
because they believe
like uh catholics don't believe in
contraception bro they don't believe in
the use of like condoms and [ __ ] like
that why because sex should only be done
to conceivably two little boys
yeah yeah yeah yeah i said it
the [ __ ] out of here it's not wrong it's
not wrong the evidence supports it yeah
it's like hey it's not [ __ ] it's not
[ __ ] these sick [ __ ] priests right
well that's what i'm like this is what
this is this is so ridiculous like yeah
it's it's comical almost right it's like
okay let me tell you the highest up of
your of your religious faction the
catholic church is raping little boys
and you want to talk about having a
moral stance yeah on on what yeah on
don't don't have sex for pleasure at all
you guys be [ __ ] oh come on and you
want to know why because let me tell you
something every guy loved catholic girls
but they're freakiest little things out
there dude there's that whole um fetish
with like the catholic school girl
outfit you know well they were always
the freak the victim these catholic
girls were [ __ ] wild
because they're so deprived yeah you
know
they're
taught to [ __ ] suppress all of that
in their sexuality and desires and it
comes out in weird [ __ ] ways
they were [ __ ] kneeling at the pulpit
at church but they were kneeling at my
house sucking dirt
and i loved it yeah praise the lord but
you know all of that is just come on man
a lot of these people in power who are
spewing all of these things it's just a
[ __ ] front you know damn well some of
these politicians have had [ __ ]
secret abortions happen because they got
their side [ __ ] probably 100 sure and
like this is not even [ __ ] hearsay
dude like i said i grew up in in the
christian church yeah right yeah like
and i know a lot of people who are
catholics and a majority of my friends
were catholics they also kill
people they had the whole rosary [ __ ]
they had the [ __ ] virgin mary crossed
the whole thing the whole [ __ ] nine
yards dude like i said those sweet sweet
girls that were that consistently went
to catholic church they were the
freakiest little things out there yeah
and i loved it every second of it
whenever they let me talk to them it was
great yeah but you know these these
group of guys um
hold themselves
to
a higher i guess degree right they
consider themselves like
doing god's work and maybe some of them
actually believe it some of them
actually might believe it but
i i don't think it's far-fetched to say
that
decent amount of them just do it
for
public face and to get into power
because you have to rub your shoulders
with some of these people clearly they
have a lot of influences uh a lot of
influence and can put you in a position
of power right but in order to do that
you got to play nice with them and you
got to also believe in what they will
believe in what they believe
at least
with your public persona
and so yeah that was the thing as like
conservatives were losing this culture
war
they realized like the only way that
we're gonna be able to turn this around
is to stack the courts
that's what they did
they put justices in the supreme court
justice who shared the same ideologies
as them you know who's gonna further
their agenda and put forth the things
that they find important yeah not what
the american people find important what
they find important and so
oh this we have freedoms and liberties
and all that but like who's really
[ __ ] deciding everything calling all
the shots man it's old rich white man
old rich white powerful religious white
man
yeah and you know i think like growing
up in a christian household too and like
i said i even growing up with like
people who are hyper catholic like i
said i'm not [ __ ] on the religion or
anything like that yeah it's just the
idea of people who put that religion as
like their identity they don't follow
through with it and so the idea that
this is for some kind of holy crusade is
a farce
it's absolutely stupid it doesn't make
sense yeah and on top of that too it's
just clearly the agenda isn't for them
to you know uplift god but they use that
because it's such a good powerful tool
to get the public to back them up
exactly exactly but but again the sad
thing is it's like i love god he's great
praise be to god nobody loves god more
than me i love god more than everybody
on this earth i just grabbed him by the
[ __ ]
no but
again bro
the sad thing is is that it stems from
these religious white religious
conservatives and
their desire and
their attempts to to basically hold on
to power and have influence you know
they didn't want that slipping away and
they used abortion as a as a basically a
stepping stone for that and then these
other issues kind of came into the fold
and it trickled down it trickled down it
didn't only indoctrinate um
the i guess politicians some of the
politicians but like some general
american population right you see again
you see these minority girls who are out
here talking about this is one of the
happiest days of my life for roe v wade
to get overturned he was 18 years old
just [ __ ] graduated high school right
talking about it's the happiest day of
their [ __ ] life to see roe v wade get
overturned
yet it stemmed from your oppressors who
thought you were subhuman at best
at best they thought you're a [ __ ]
animal that's why they didn't want their
[ __ ] kids in the same vicinity as you
didn't even want their [ __ ] sharing
the same bathroom as you where you take
a [ __ ] and a piss because your [ __ ] and
piss is [ __ ] disgusting to them yeah
these are the people who came up with
these ideologies
and it [ __ ] trickled down in 2022 to
these minorities
who spew and regurgitate that same thing
that their [ __ ] oppressors
that their oppressors [ __ ] created
and they're sitting you're talking about
is the best day of their life because
they think again that
their
thoughts and beliefs on this is
of their own
it's not yeah it's not it was a [ __ ]
power play and it worked it worked ever
since the god damn 80s and it's trickled
down since like i wonder too like with
the with you know
you know for 18 year old who's in that
situation yeah let's say that they um
especially because technology now you
can actually see like genetic defects or
whatever that your child will have
before they're born right or you know
before you give birth to them like the
child's in the womb whatever you know
okay well there's a chance that this kid
could you know down syndrome or whatever
you know early on before this
if you ask me
or you know it'll be you know a
conversation with me and mariel i'm
pretty sure we would choose
to probably abort that child because the
quality of life for that kid is going to
be terrible and to be honest with you if
i would be really honest my quality of
life is well too yeah like to be having
to take care of this and then after we
pass this child has to somehow survive
and live
like
i couldn't live with that yeah i mean
and they're like well how are you gonna
take joy away from this child what the
[ __ ] do you know yeah what do you know
like being in school and seeing those
parents like struggle
you know trying to just number one like
normalize their life normalize their
kids life normalize their life and
having to see like i i was at a cafe not
too long ago
and i and you know
um i don't know exactly what the ailment
was but it was you know
you could tell like they're some type of
like what's what's the politically
correct term like mental retardation or
some sort right is that it what is it is
that the
mental retardation is not i don't think
used anymore um
i don't know that sounds offensive as
[ __ ] to me too though yeah disability
disability disabled yeah
i thought that was the pc dc version
yeah no it is
yeah that's what we used and we didn't
you know it wasn't we thought it was pc
at the time yeah it wasn't a derogatory
thing
yeah the um like there was a kid who was
like mentally disabled
and
i'm not sure if they have a shorter
lifespan or whatever but there was like
this older parent and they were still
watching over this kid and i'm pretty
sure they love their child or whatever
right but
and you know whatever their personal
relationship i don't really know or
understand yeah but this person is a
caretaker of this human being since they
were one all the way till they were 50.
and they still have to take care of them
all the time um that's a huge
responsibility to take on for people who
aren't ready for that maybe these
parents weren't they they have a very
loving life which is understandable and
that's very beautiful but that's not to
say that's for everybody yeah because i
don't think i could handle that [ __ ]
yeah right and i don't want to grow up
uh raising this child and resenting this
kid every day because i didn't get to
live my life because i have to you know
and i know it sounds selfish for a lot
of people who maybe who are not
pro-choice but these are things that
are viable reasons for abortion in my
personal opinion
i mean look when it makes um
a big enough impact in your life like
those decisions matter bro i mean look
me i'm pro-choice but growing up i had
pregnancy scares with like girls i was
with like girlfriends or whatever right
let's say the prospect of having a child
when i'm 18 years old
is [ __ ] terrifying yeah right i was
like holy [ __ ] i'm not ready just
because i'm pro-choice it wasn't like
okay well abortion
it was still a thought process okay let
me weigh this out can i possibly bring a
child into this world if i do what's
that what is that gonna look like how am
i gonna be able to handle it and talk
with the girl too right how do you feel
about it do you think you might be able
to ready to bring a challenge this will
carry this you know um fetus into a
child and birth this and have our lives
be changed forever and linked forever as
a result of this
just because i'm pro-choice doesn't mean
it's an automatic thing of abort
done well yeah and that's the thing too
that i that i kind of find issue with
when
um people talk about it they go you're
just gonna give up a life so easy i was
like who said it was easy yeah it's not
a [ __ ] easy decision man were you
with the these these women or the you
know the couple that was there that had
to decide to let go of this child like
who said it was easy you said it was
easy to go through this whole procedure
i don't understand why you're assuming
like for them it's like you know like
changing underwear like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about yeah i mean people
go through depression after you know
they abort a baby right
there there there there are clear signs
that it's not a [ __ ] easy decision
for them and it's made an impact on
their life as a result of it you know
but
some people who are
anti-abortion
seem to have this idea that if you're
pro-choice
you're just okay with it it's just roll
off my [ __ ] shoulders and it's
an easy thing to do yeah and then they
go well you should have never had sex
yeah you never had [ __ ] all right
you don't know how good that feels all
right you don't you don't know the
addiction behind it
um here was another crazy thing that i
had learned through reading about this
but um jane roe
of roe v wade did you know that she
became a anti-abortion advocate
really so in 95 i believe it was um she
flipped the script and became an
anti-abortion advocate right now here's
the thing here's the interesting thing
so she she was like that until her
deathbed so for for years and years and
years she became anti-abortion people
like what the [ __ ] this whole case roe v
you're wrong roe v wade right
on her deathbed she admitted
yeah actually
i'm not anti-abortion anti-abortion
advocates came to me and they paid me a
lot of [ __ ] money to turn code and i
was good at it so i took their money i
didn't believe in their ideals i just
did it
but i am not anti-abortion
[Laughter]
how much money did they get i mean but
it must have been a lot the [ __ ] that i
just told you look at these people
they're not [ __ ] just some you know
jump off the whole block these guys are
people in power with money and sway and
you know yeah so this [ __ ] hood
hopping [ __ ]
you [ __ ] a hood hopping heifer
how how dare you
so these fools just came to her door to
like hey listen i got a bag of cash and
this is what we're gonna do
i'm gonna slide you this money
but you gotta say that you're
anti-abortion till the day you do
10 minutes before you die you could tell
people that you're not but
you got to keep your mouth shut until
then she was like
bet yeah and then she just clicked the
camera i'm trying to get this bag
really yeah
that is wild that is [ __ ] wild that's
the craziest thing i'm saying man this
everything behind roe v wade is not just
like what people know about on the
surface level it's not just about
abortion rights yes of course that's
like you know cream of the crop part of
the issue but
all the history and context behind it
these religious groups these men in
power and and how they basically
indoctrinated people and it trickled
down and even the [ __ ] people
involved in this with jane roe being
like yeah nah i'm anti-abortion not just
kidding i just was getting the bag that
is the craziest thing i've ever heard in
my life dude it's pretty ridiculous this
spineless [ __ ] yeah that is the most
spineless thing that she could have ever
done yeah but at the same time i wonder
what her situation maybe she was broke
out of her mouth i mean [ __ ] but she
said it was a lot of money she said it
was a lot of money and that she might be
millions i'm sure
i'm sure it changed her her life pretty
much [ __ ] maybe i would have taken the
money too
[Music]
like if it was like if it was like so
versus i don't know
the state silver's weighed
like what was it for it's like the stop
asian hate and they're like hey say that
you don't believe in that [ __ ] all right
missed 20 million dollars you were
willing to suck dick for ten thousand
dollars i think you're invited
than that
you give me way too much credit
they want you to go outside and tell
people that asian hate doesn't exist
here's 20 million dollars [ __ ] i
don't know
i don't know
listen here guys just hear me out hear
me huh all i'm saying is
maybe
maybe asian hate doesn't exist and you
guys are all trippy i'm about to be like
kyle renton house trying to sell this
[ __ ] game app selling turkeys
did you hear that [ __ ] well he said what
so kyle renton house has this um
this app that he put out yeah where it's
him
shooting a bunch of turkeys and he's
like
you know kind of flying to the fact that
he was the guy that [ __ ] went out
there and was like a renegade yeah which
makes me so irritated because
he literally said in public that he
wants to put this whole thing behind him
that he doesn't want any public pub like
publicity whatever his fool is milking
the [ __ ] out of it this little [ __ ]
dweeb yeah needs to get his ass beat so
bad is he selling the app yeah he's
selling that he's making money off of it
so he's doing he has pre-orders for it
and guess what the theme song is him
rapping oh no
he
why is he rapping where does that go
[ __ ] no
what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] walmart parking lot [ __ ]
savior dweeb like the [ __ ] is wrong with
you dude like i literally i mean look
the evidence is the evidence right
whatever you know you got lucky you
happen to have killed the [ __ ] sexual
predator
all the [ __ ] just [ __ ]
all the ducks were in a row for you dude
you are so [ __ ] lucky you piece of
[ __ ] but then after when he said like
listen like i thought i was doing
something good i wanna i don't wanna be
in the public eye anymore it's all
[ __ ] now yeah it's like you're
[ __ ] milking this you little piece of
[ __ ] wow yeah he is milking it if you
[ __ ] creating a turkey
how how [ __ ] how much more white can
i get
it's like gun rights [ __ ] stuff that
he's doing he's shooting turkey
whoever buys that [ __ ] app you're
such a loser dude oh my god dude i'll
tell you this world is going [ __ ]
crazy
it is [ __ ] going crazy man like i was
just telling you before we started was
that we haven't gotten off the crazy
train since 2020. we've been steadily
this [ __ ]
crazy train is chewing along and
coal keeps getting thrown into the
[ __ ] fire and it's going strong man
and this whole roe v way thing
it wasn't a complete surprise because we
had those leaked documents saying that
you know they're considering working on
some [ __ ] yeah and and people were like
oh [ __ ] this actually might happen and
it wasn't the first time that they tried
to overturn roe v wade i believe in the
90s they were trying to do it too um
they or they wanted to but they ended up
not going through with it for some
reason i don't i don't exactly remember
but yeah dude just me
reading into kind of like how
how we got to where we are today it
[ __ ] blew my mind and with the cherry
on top being the [ __ ] whole jane rose
story about yo that she's a hood hopping
home
and
i couldn't even imagine like just
thinking about like in general
could you imagine
having to force a woman to have a child
uh that was a product of like sexual
assault and rape i know and then that
child looks exactly like her assailant
and she has she has to somehow mentally
move passes i mean it's a child it's
innocent yeah but that child looks
exactly the person that raped him raped
her like
i
we know of people
who
mistreat their children because they
blame their shitty life circumstances on
a child that they wanted to have yeah
could you only imagine like the quality
of life that this kid is gonna have
saying that's what i'm saying it's like
you gotta take all of those things into
consideration and [ __ ] man not even just
um an assailant or a rapist that's a
stranger but
in sexual rape right like oh my god like
if it's [ __ ] your dad who raped you
and impregnated you and now you need to
have your [ __ ] you're going to give
birth to your sister
dude
how weird [ __ ] yeah right wrong on so
many levels they say we're not uh we're
just saying [ __ ] england
but that was true though like back in
the day because they wanted to keep
royal blood yeah pure they would [ __ ]
their family members and there would be
a lot of like birth defects yeah yeah
that's exactly what it was i mean
stepping back to [ __ ] like
uh ancient times you know with like
egyptians and all of that but yeah dude
to to force a person
saying
what you want essentially doesn't matter
now because you have a human being like
at conception right because as they
believe life happens at conception
you have a human being now inside of you
and now it is your
responsibility
to birth that human being
yeah
i disagree
yeah
i disagree vehemently i disagree yeah
because i think a lot of people [ __ ]
disagree yeah yeah well again majority
of americans do disagree um but
i don't know man some of these people
and and look maybe it would have uh been
dope to have um
a woman on the podcast talking about
this too because i would really like to
hear their point of view because they're
the ones who have to carry the child for
nine months right and and then and then
birth the child i don't even understand
like how are we not passed the idea to
of
the whole same-sex marriage thing
like
i don't get why it's such a big deal
like because that right there is against
god's will hey just because they can't
get married doesn't mean they're not out
there [ __ ] licking [ __ ] and sucking
dick
it's not gonna change the fact that
they're gay yeah it's just gonna allow
them to have i don't know the same
rights as everybody [ __ ] else
that's human decency that's a that's a
really interesting point though right
because jesus they use um
their
religious beliefs and the bible to say
that homosexuality is a sin right they
all eat shrimp though
you know you know they're supposed to
eat those shrimp and pork right they're
bottom feeding animals but here's but
here's the thing though right there's
some scientific evidence that uh they
can be born this way that their brain
activity mirrors that closer to a
biological female
your ear
saint satan was
saying didn't god don't make no gays see
the satans do but that's the thing you
need to you need to have like a
disconnect with certain things in order
to use the bible and your religious
beliefs to like really back up certain
things back up on uh back up certain
issues very sensitive issues hey science
is gay that's what that is right
science is about the gayest thing i ever
heard
right you tell me bill not a science guy
well it's funny ain't gay it's funny
because they will cherry pick science
when it's
supportive of their arguments and their
ideologies but that's how whatever
refutes it
then science be them hey
i picked my information like adam cherry
picked that apple off that tree or was
it eve and look i'm saying all this as
as a christian man you know as a
christian i'm a god-believing christian
man you know but a lot of these things
i have my beefs with with the way
the conservative christians you know um
interpret it
and look i i i can't say i'm right or
they're right or whatever um i just
disagree with some of these things when
i feel like it should just be basic
human rights you know who who the [ __ ]
are we who the [ __ ] are who the matter
of fact who the [ __ ] are you you old
[ __ ] white man to tell any women in
this country what they can and can't do
with their body or one of the supreme
court justices was a black dude too yeah
yeah he is one of the dudes but
one
black dude yeah
you know you know what his name is
clayton bixby
[Laughter]
for those of you guys who don't know
clayton bixby look up clayton big z on
youtube and you will get the rest
that's a clayton bixby right there dude
yeah that that is but no i mean six of
the nine
uh supreme court justices are
conservative so clearly
it's gonna favor them uh it's gonna
favor the conservative party when
they're talking about things like this
and
it's just it's [ __ ] crazy to me that
nine
people get to
make a [ __ ] decision like this that
impacts a lot of [ __ ] people a lot of
women a lot of women a lot of women and
there's what
one
supreme court amy coney barrett i think
she's the only or was there two there's
i think there was a newly appointed
i'm not sure i'm not sure either yeah
it's it's easy one or two women max
um
but yeah it's uh
old again old
white
rich and powerful men deciding what you
can and can't do in this country and
that is the story of america my friends
i science is gay everybody
science is gay
that's that's what we take away from all
this that's that science is gay i'm
letting y'all know right now science is
gay and if you believe in science that's
the gay thing i read you are the gayest
dude or boy
it's not allowed because it's not
science yeah but crazy times man crazy
[ __ ] times well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
uh if you guys have your own two cents
about this especially if you're a woman
that we would like to hear in the
comments
right away because this [ __ ] is my
personal opinion is [ __ ] wrong yeah
it's crazy but yeah i would love to hear
you know the the viewpoints and opinions
of everybody yeah and i really would
suggest people
you know
and i know that it's hard for a lot of
people to do this especially when we
have a
stance that's so
just on the polar opposite side of what
this decision is but in order for you to
really have a conversation with somebody
to get them to understand your point you
have to understand their point first not
just only to refute what they say but if
they know more about a subject than you
do about something that you truly
believe in that you're never going to be
able to have a conversation with them
right right it's it's too difficult yeah
like i said when i had that moment with
someone you know talking about you know
when i was you know growing up in a
christian household talking about crisis
somebody they knew more about me i
looked like an idiot so like yeah it was
kind of rough watching those videos you
know it was rough it was a lot of videos
i didn't watch but like i said their
main argument you know seemingly is that
it's murder and that's really about it
yeah but once again
i don't even know scientifically that's
even true up to a certain point yeah
yeah up to a certain point yeah yeah so
i don't know um
write in the comments below what you
think uh you catch ed at ed2 and uh
secret society s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
[Music]
uh spring stuff is a lot of the stuff is
out yeah yeah how many people people
have been [ __ ] with it man i think
there's like 39 things left 37
but
catch those if you can there's a few
shirts left a couple of shorts here and
there we still have um a few other
restocks that we've done so check it out
access we'll have more restocks on the
way too for like the back to basic stuff
and then we'll also try to restock them
vintage shoes there's a lot of things
going on right now and we're a very
small team so bear with us guys thank
you guys for the support first of all
but yeah please bear with us and we'll
get this [ __ ] popping yep uh just rain
every sunday at 12 p.m and we'll see you
all next time all right peace